unsere dritte bewohner sendung im
absolut stillen studie und ich muss
sagen ich habe mich inzwischen daran
gewöhnt wer braucht applaus wenn er das
lachen seiner kameraleute hat ja eine
historische woche liegt hinter uns liebe
zuschauer angela merkel hat das land
erstmals von zu hause aus regiert aus
der quarantäne muss sagen mir ist kein
großer unterschied aufgefallen positiv
denken heißt jetzt die devise positiv
denken denn es gibt ja noch gute
nachrichten hier zum beispiel hat es
gelesen
der verband der hefe industrie teilt
offiziell mit zitat deutschlands
versorgung mit hilfe ist gesichert
hefe und noch eine gute nachricht die
deutschen hamstern inzwischen wohl
zumindest etwas weniger denn da fällt
mir ein wussten sie eigentlich was nicht
hamstern in holländischer
gebärdensprache heißen ob er ihn nicht
daran hamster sich nicht nur durch die
kamst du denn nicht zu verwechseln mit
dieser geste
das ist hbo 12 man lernt so viel in
diesen tagen ja nicht nur schön ist wenn
man lernt so viel zurück zur
bundeskanzlerin sie hat letzten sonntag
uns alle das ganze land quasi auf die
stille treppe gesetzt zu recht zurecht
und weizen nicht anders geht
die meisten deutschen haben zwar längst
verstanden wie abstand halten geht und
wie wichtig zu hause bleiben in diesen
tagen ist aber wegen einer handvoll
unverbesserlicher dödel gilt jetzt eben
für uns alle eine nacht erster kontakt
dings und deshalb halte ich ein
kontaktverbot ab zwei personen für das
geeignete mittel
alles klar kontaktverbot ab zwei
personen sagt der army was übrigens
totaler quatsch ist in wirklichkeit ist
natürlich ein kontaktverbot ab der
dritten person ja erst mal in der
dritten person wird quasi illegal
neuerdings da kommen
das ist nicht schlimm da ist er kurz
durcheinandergekommen entscheidend ist
ja wir haben ein kontaktverbot so weit
verstanden dass wir die kontakte
reduzieren
ach so ein kontaktverbot kann
reduzierung frage hätte man sich da
nicht auf eigene formulierung naja egal
geht ja ungefähr in dieselbe richtung
prinzip ist klar zwei personen dürfen
sich draußen bewegen mehr ist verboten
haben jetzt alle verstanden darf ich
wirklich nur noch alleine raus gehen
nein nein
maximal zwei hast du nicht einst
hoffnungslos es ist hoffnungslos
andererseits sind die politiker auch ein
stückweit selber schuld an der ganzen
verwirrung meine laschet und merkel
reden von kontaktverbot oder meinetwegen
reduzierung in bayern und im saarland
gilt weiter die ausgangs beschränkung
einigen uns auf kontakt sperren
ausgangsverbot beschränkung 3000 punkte
beim scrabble in nrw zum beispiel darf
die zweite person ein fremder seien in
bayern muss sie irgendwie zur familie
gehören in sachsen wiederum ist bewegung
an der frischen luft erlaubt aber nur
zitat im umfeld des wohnbereichs egal
fakt ist ja wir bürger machen längst mit
und wir bürger machen das beste draus zb
beim skypen mit oma kontakt mit der oma
haben bendix und anne zurzeit nur im
videochat auch manch oma du hast das
video angehalten umwelt so alleine
reicht wohl nicht
tatsächlich ist es doch toll es ist doch
toll wie unsere jungen menschen jetzt
die alten draußen schützen wie alle
mitmachen also die meisten trotz der
vielen einschränkungen die kontaktverbot
natürlich mit sich bringen es hat viele
folgen in dem bereich kinder kinder zum
beispiel geht heute so gar nicht mehr im
grunde das ganze konzept sex mit fremden
erotik trotz kontaktverbot das kroner
sutra hemmungslose leidenschaft ohne
inflationsrisiko mit neueinstellungen
wie der skype in ekstase telefonsex bei
der die frau vor langeweile schon längst
can dekra spielt für fortgeschrittene
der vor der glotze eingeschlafenen lotus
oder die sicherste stellung von allen
die abstand halten die tigerin und
der weit in der ferne onanieren de affe
[Musik]
sex mit kontaktverbot in den meisten
beziehungen dürfte das wenig ändern
ansonsten hat der unter corona
bedingungen tagen der bundestag gerade
geschichte geschrieben
das ist nicht übertrieben geschichte in
nur einer woche wurde ein gigantisches
hilfspaket für wirtschaft und
krankenhäuser auf den weg gebracht gut
ab der größte rettungsschirm aller
zeiten gab nie in größeren schirm mit
staatlichen bürgschaften von bis zu 1,5
billionen euro
wow wow sieht sich eine astronomische
aber auch völlig abstrakte zahl wenn
jetzt mal ernsthaft 1,5 billionen ist
das viel
experten gehen davon aus dass diese
komplette corona krise den deutschen
staat so viel kosten wird wie die
deutsche einheit damals nicht nochmal
die deutsche einheit gut unsere
politiker können im moment natürlich nur
auf sicht fahren und müssen allen
respekt dafür ernsthaft bret harte
entscheidungen treffen
red hatte entscheidung was ist jetzt
gerade die richtige exit strategie aus
der ganzen sache wie lange kann man eine
ganze volkswirtschaft ins künstliche
koma versetzen wie wir das gerade machen
also quasi diese unmögliche abwägung
wirtschaft gesundheit
das heißt man kann gar nicht eine
perfekt laufende wirtschaft und keine
erkrankten haben es geht parallel ein
wähler noch umgekehrt genauso nicht denn
wenn es keine menschen mehr gibt dann
hat die wirtschaft auch keine kunden
mehr sollte man nicht vergessen menschen
sind immer auch kunden
was hat politik in dieser lage überhaupt
noch für spielräume was soll man da
machen
zitat horst seehofer wirtschaftliche
interessen dürfen den schutz von
menschenleben nicht überlagern war
völlig richtig jedes wort allerdings
darf ich mal erinnern hat dieselbe
gruppe jahre lang aus rücksicht auf die
autoindustrie strengere abgaswerte
verhindert und auch daran sterben jedes
jahr viele menschen will damit nur sagen
macht das mit dem schutz von
menschenleben gern auch nach corona
weiter ansonsten gab es hinter den
kulissen wohl noch zoff zwischen unseren
ministerpräsidenten und präsidentinnen
es im kern geht es darum manche finden
wo das sich ein gewisser markus sie
da in der krise ein bisschen zu sehr
profiliert also im sinne von stadt
föderalismus mehr so süde realismus
nicht dabei ist vieles was er vorschlägt
überhaupt nicht verkehrt ganz im
gegenteil überhaupt nicht verkehrt
deswegen ist er ja gerade so ein
wahnsinnig begehrter interviewpartner
ja da gibt es zumindest viel zu
besprechen und das wollen wir machen
natürlich mit dem gebotenen
sicherheitsabstand unter den gebotenen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen mit dem
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten dr
markus söder ich grüße ganz herzlich
wurden morgan creek gute morgen können
sie mich noch sehen korrekte abstand
söder gibt im land den takt an
sicherlich ist da nicht jeder vorschlag
pures gold wenn er zum beispiel einfach
mal verkündet supermärkte haben ab
sofort auch sonntags auf dann sagen die
betreiber zu recht ja toll
dann sitzt du dich noch an die kasse
söder ja wir haben nämlich leider kein
personal in der hinterhand wusstest du
gar nicht mehr
immerhin der mann weiß dafür
offensichtlich wie führung in
krisenzeiten geht und das ist ja wichtig
jetzt wo die kanzlerin in quarantäne ist
und der bundestag ausgedünnt da stellt
sich schon die bange frage wer regiert
uns eigentlich wenn das alles noch
schlimmer würde ich leite die mal weiter
an unseren katzentisch
dort sitzt der staatsrechtler albrecht
humboldt albrecht muss man sich sorgen
machen
nein der bundestag hat ja jetzt
beschlossen dass er zur not auch nur mit
einem viertel der abgeordneten
beschlussfähig ist
außerdem und das sage ich ihnen jetzt
mal als mensch und nicht als jurist
spätestens seit dieser woche ist ja wohl
jedem klar wer uns hier zur not regiert
vier worte
markus thomas theodor heine sich auch
noch um bolt ja wer denn sonst
deutschlands krisenmanager numero uno es
ist
das war wie gut er das macht dieser
macher steht da wie eine eiche
entschlossen überlegt männlich sie sind
aber nicht sexuell erregt oder ja und
wenn schon
dieser wurde geboren für krisen jeder
satz wie aus einem 90er jahre actionfilm
irgendwo brennt vulkan bricht aus gebt
mir fackeln markus söder ich und wir
können nicht verantworten zu warten
jetzt einfach die zeit zu handeln und
nicht endlos zu debattieren und zu
vertagen wir handeln immer angemessen
aber ehrlich gesagt auch entschlossen
ehrlicherweise mein ganzer tag richtet
sich ausschließlich darauf das
management zu entscheiden
wir sind vorangegangen ja viele sind
gefolgt ich möchte dass wir keinen tag
zögern whatever it takes hat man muss
man auch ein stück weit vorangehen damit
auch die möglichkeit besteht dass alle
mitmachen
jetzt in heute shop das neue zelda fan
shirt man muss auch mal vorangehen damit
die möglichkeit besteht dass alle
mitmachen
verstehen sie erbrecht ja nur vor damit
die luschen aus den anderen versager
ländern die chance haben ihn zu folgen
ja ich habe das schon kapiert und ich
finde tatsächlich dass er ein sehr sehr
guter krisenmanager ist aber wenn man
zwei tage vor der konferenz der
länderchefs eine eigene lösung nur für
bayern präsentiert er hunger hat das ja
schon einen hauch von alpha rödl
also bitte sie stellen das jetzt da als
ob der sünder alles alleine entscheiden
will
es stimmt doch gar nicht der lässt uns
bürgern enorme spielräume und
friseurbesuche müssen jetzt die menschen
sich wie früher vielleicht auch zeiten
des krieges oder danach die haare selbst
schneiden wie immer an seine frisur
gestaltet bleibt ihm selbst überlassen
so nämlich wir dürfen unsere frisuren
selber gestalten das zeichnet ja einen
großen herrscher aus dass er auch mal
delegiert fun fact am rande herr söder
schneidet sich seine haare tatsächlich
seit jahren selber und es sieht trotzdem
perfekt aus bei frisuren kann ich eh
nicht mitreden trotzdem noch mal die
frage an den juristen
wie läuft das denn weiter mit dem
kabinett in berlin jetzt wo frau merkel
erst mal zu hause bleibt
ja da gibt es tatsächlich eine gute und
eine schlechte nachricht die gute zuerst
olaf scholz kann als vizekanzler
theoretisch noch wochenlang sämtliche
kabinettssitzung leiten aha und die
schlechte die schlechte nachricht ist
sollte auch noch olaf scholz ausfallen
und zu hause bleiben könnten er und die
kanzlerin laut geschäftsordnung einen
beliebigen bundesminister zum leiter des
kabinetts ernennen ist ihnen klar was
das im worst case bedeutet gott stehe
uns allen bei albrecht humboldt
vielen dank albrecht humboldt ja gerade
mal fünf tage kontaktverbot
entschuldigung reduzierung bzw
ausgangssperren beschränkung liegen
hinter uns deutschen und schon wollen
die ersten politiker aus union und fdp
über eine lockerung diskutieren extrem
unklug signal finde ich an eine ansicht
doch geduldige bevölkerung meine klar
kommt irgendwann der sogenannte
lagerkoller aber dagegen kann man ja was
tun meint friedemann weise ratschläge in
die fresse mit friedemann weise nach
zwei wochen home office fangen die leute
langsam an ihren gewohnten büroalltag zu
vermissen aber das muss nicht sein
im netz gibt es schöne ideen wie man zum
beispiel die morgendliche bahnfahrt zu
hause simulieren kann
wenn man das macht nachdem die kinder
alle auf toilette waren hat man sogar
den geruch einer berliner u bahn und
auto pendler können den morgendlichen
stau ganz einfach mit der familie vor
dem badezimmer nachspielen man braucht
etwas worüber man sich aufregen kann
versuchen sie im home-office die büro
situation so genau wie möglich
nachzubilden
das fängt beim kaffee an wenn sie da
einfach ein löffel entkalker dazu
mischen schmeckt der kaffee zu hause
genauso schlimm wie auf der arbeit auch
auf büro humor muss man im home-office
nicht verzichten
der klassiker nackt auf den kopierer
setzen lässt sich auch zuhause
realisieren
alles was sie dafür brauchen ist ein
glas tisch ein smartphone und etwas
fantasie
vor allem aber brauchen wir ablenkungen
fernsehen bietet sich an
ich gucke mittlerweile alles also alles
was nicht um corona geht sogar kochshows
das bild kartoffel kurz abgebildet
anschließend durchgedrückt und jetzt
brauchen wir etwas gries gebrauchen
etwas mail.ru der feine herr roßmeier
hat noch mehr
ich brauche ja mittlerweile mit kokain
da kriegt man leichter man muss schon
genau aufpassen was man guckt zum
beispiel bars für rares kann ich im
moment nicht mehr gucken war schlimm
ich habe gar nicht so viele hände die
ich mir da waschen
will dann lieber auf nummer sicher eine
zdf wohlfühl serie
damit kann man eigentlich nie was falsch
machen eine glückliche familie
wir sind in frankreich das nach
frankreich über die grenze ohne
kontrolle total unrealistisch aber zu
viel fernsehen ist ja ähnlich gut warum
nicht mal wieder wie früher mit den
kindern was basteln zb eine schöne düfte
orange es ist gut fürs raumklima und
sieht schön aus
obwohl er warte mal an irgendwas
erinnert mich das teil
ok ich gebe es auf gute besserung
thielemann weise so unterdessen stellt
sich raus unser gesundheitssystem ist
doch nicht so optimal auf corona
vorbereitet wie wir gehofft hatten
es mangelt an medizintechnik aber vor
allem an schutzkleidung atemschutzmasken
ja dabei wurde das
gesundheitsministerium dabei wurde jan
sparen schon anfang februar von
großhändlern ausdrücklich genau davor
gewarnt und klar weil wenn unser staat
pendler dann muss man es halt woanders
versuchen der landrat des kreises
heinsberg hat sich vergangene woche
sogar schriftlich an die chinesische
regierung gewandt und um hilfe gebeten
die hier vorhandenen schutz materialien
reichen zurzeit nur für ein paar tage in
meiner funktion als landrat bitte ich
daher die volksrepublik china um
unterstützung sodass also einmal die
nummer 28 peking ente süß-sauer und
100.000 schutzmasken bitte ja roman der
kreis heinsberg geht offiziell fremd ja
ja ja und man kann es ihnen nicht
verübeln
man kann es ihnen überhaupt nicht
verüben in dem fall deutschland
scheitert hier bei den atemschutzmasken
ja nicht an hightech sondern an einem
einwegprodukte peinlich unsere
krankenhäuser kämpfen verzweifelt um
schutzkleidung und zahlen dabei
wucherpreise da werden bis zu 30 euro
für masken verlangt die vor der krise
69 cent gekostet haben jetzt überhaupt
noch masken kriegen das ist ja schlicht
glückssache
wenn sie überhaupt ihr denn die maske
wir haben den bürgern wir überhaupt
nicht mehr bei uns im kranken
wir haben geschenkt bekommen von den
patienten wie nett oder
heute musste als patient auch einfach
mal mit helfen warum nicht das eigene
op-besteck mitbringen warum nicht viele
niedergelassene ärzte haben in dieser
situation gar keine schutzkleidung mehr
sollen die alle dicht machen demnächst
ja ich fürchte entweder das oder halt
improvisieren er hat momentan nur zwei
stück und das eher zufällig kam jetzt
fdp drei masten über beziehung von den
landwirten bekommen also die das eben
als schutzkleidung für infizierte stelle
haben ist doch kein problem so kein
problem wenn die schweine haben die ja
meist nur einmal benutzt sind doch noch
gut und genauso dramatisch ist übrigens
bei den desinfektionsmitteln kann wird
die firma jägermeister hilft jetzt mit
bei der produktion von
desinfektionsmittel geschmacklich ändert
sich da also nichts
manches wird man halt neu denken müssen
in der zeit nachgeholt
auch die tatsache dass viele unserer
wichtigsten medikamente aus
kostengründen in china und indien
produziert werden fällt uns jetzt leider
auf die füße wir sind in der
abhängigkeit also sehr sarkastisch
formuliert sage ich gerne die chinesen
brauchen gar keine atombombe
sie liefern einfach keine antibiotika
und dann erledigt sich europa man muss
ein bisschen warten atombombe geht
schneller
aber dann erledigt sich europa von
alleine vielen dank gute laune oma von
der uni würzburg
leider hat sie total recht mit dem was
sie da sagt wir haben uns bei vielen
medikamenten bei immer mehr medikamenten
abhängig gemacht und das
gesundheitssystem ist insgesamt viel zu
sehr auf kante genäht
ja deswegen wurde kaum schutzkleidung
auf vorrat gelagert
es kostet ja geld und deswegen haben wir
jahrelang ausgerechnet am pflegepersonal
gespart tatsache von 1995 bis heute ist
zwar die zahl der ärzte bei uns
kontinuierlich gestiegen die der
pflegekräfte aber um 7,7 prozent
gesunken
gesunken ja und jetzt in der korona
krise logisch sind natürlich bald
pfleger und ärzte am limit total am
limit
bitte nicht falsch verstehen im
gesundheitssystem ist schon genug geld
es wird noch oft falsch ausgegeben
seit bei uns pro fall bezahlt wird lohnt
sich zb eine
op viel mehr als irgendeine
langzeitbehandlung immerhin stellt ihren
sparen jetzt wegen corona bis zu zehn
milliarden euro für kliniken bereit und
für jedes zusätzliche intensivbetten
50.000 euro 50.000 doch gut oder
die deutschen können das gesellschaft
hat ermittelt dass ein intensiv platz
oder ein behandlungsplatz 85.000 euro
kostet das wäre doch eine schöne aufgabe
für unser kommendes notabitur wenn etwas
85.000 kostet und man kriegt 50.000
reicht das dann ja oder nein
beim nrw gelten übrigens beide antworten
als bestanden
aber zurück zur pflege bei der pflege
waren bundesweit schon vor coroner
17.000 stellen unbesetzt
die pflegerinnen und pfleger die wir
noch haben sind seit jahren überlastet
weiß jeder
und offensichtlich erwartet man bei
dieser berufsgruppe regelrecht du hast
die sich aus nächstenliebe einfach immer
weiter so reinhängen jaja hat sich doch
bewährt hat sich doch bewährt warum das
ändern
so gesehen war es auch sagen wir mal
eine dufte geste vom bundestag dass die
abgeordneten diese woche stimmt für
unsere pflegerinnen und pfleger
absolviert haben großartig sehr gute
geste gut die grünen hatten gefordert
denen eine corona bonuszahlung zu
spendieren aber klatschen ist auch gut
und wir bürger sind ja nicht viel besser
die meisten von uns haben sie auch nie
dafür eingesetzt dass pflegeberufe
bessere arbeitsbedingungen oder mehr
geld kriegen aber dafür klatschen wir
jetzt abends
[Musik]
überlastete krankenhäuser pflegekräfte
am rande der erschöpfung sicher mehr
geld für diese helden wäre eine lösung
noch besser ist wenn sie liebe mitbürger
sich abends auf ihren balkon stellen und
klatschen
denn mal ehrlich welche währung ist
schöner als applaus deshalb spendiert
die groko jetzt sieben milliarden euro
für neue balkone sogar im erdgeschoss
wir retten unser gesundheitswesen mit
mehr balkonen gern geschehen
ihre bundesregierung
schöne aktion sehr schöne aktion
und damit ist es zeit für unsere
nagelneue rubrik corona folgen über die
man aber auch mal reden könnte beispiel
mehrere 100 tafeln mussten wegen corona
inzwischen schon dicht machen wo ist da
der rettungsschirm am besten einer dem
man essen kann oder was ist mit
obdachlosen in deutschland aber auch bei
unseren nachbarn emanuel der seit zehn
jahren auf der straße lebt sagt die
regierenden haben die obdachlosen
einfach vergessen
die regierung sagt man soll im haus
bleiben und damit bin ich einverstanden
aber wir haben keine aus ja ich fürchte
selbst mit publikum hätte an dieser
stelle niemand gelacht anderes beispiel
lkw-fahrer die brummi fahrer und
fahrerinnen also die leute die dafür
sorgen dass wieder nudeln bei uns im
regal liegen auch corona hält ganz klar
helden leider haben aber fast alle
raststätten inzwischen geschlossen
das heißt diese helden die trucker
müssen mit einer baby und zwei red bull
von warschau bis duisburg kommen und
finden unterwegs nicht mal eine saubere
toilette
er ist so eine katastrophe ist auch teil
nicht für uns alle
die agentur für arbeit befürchtet
aktuell das mindestens mindestens eine
million selbstständige bald in hartz4
fall ja klar
für die wird vorübergehend die
bedürftigkeitsprüfung ausgesetzt auch
eine entscheidung aus dieser woche aber
das ist ja trotzdem ein tragischer
abstieg vielleicht könnte man alternativ
über das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
zumindest mal diskutieren oder über elly
copter geld zumindest diskutieren
auch bei gastronomen spielen sich gerade
echte dramen ab im elbschloss keller am
hamburger berg mussten sie heute erst
mal ein neues schloss einbauen
der laden hatte seit 70 jahren nicht
mehr geschlossen
im sommer wiederum ihr die tür noch mal
zu ja wenigstens arbeit für den
schlosser in dem fall vor allem viele
einzelhändler stehen bereits ganz kurz
vor dem bankrott während ausgerechnet
diese steuerhinterzieher von amazon groß
abräumen alles traurig und wie soll das
erst werden wenn irgendwann vielleicht
doch noch eine echte ausgangssperre
kommt was macht so einen lock down mit
einem psychologisch martin klempnow hat
als so genannter trepper schon vor
jahren angefangen sich mit vorräten auf
die apokalypse vorzubereiten bescheiden
mal live in seiner wohnung herr klempnow
fühlen sie sich jetzt quasi bestätigt
da ist kann man wohl sagen herr welke
wie er präpariert sind die einzigen die
vorbereitet sind
ich habe meine wohnung schon seit jahren
nicht mehr verlassen also jetzt nicht
wegen corona wegen chemtrails natürlich
aber das ist auch egal
im gegensatz zu euch zivilisations
opfern bin ich brauch keinen zum
überleben sie war anders
hallo herr lempe klemm der glückspilz
trainer war
ach ja ich bin völlig autark mit den
tonnen von mail die ich hier rum stehen
hat könnte ich mir zum beispiel jeden
tag selber pizza machen habe ich
übrigens heute zum ersten mal probiert
kann ich aber keine toilette plötzlich
sehen hier prima die sieger der
geschichte und wie wurden wir seit
jahren dargestellt im mainstream tvh als
geisteskranke waldschrate das ist ein
green tatsächlich und der soll jetzt
durch destillation wieder aufgefangen
werden das wasser als trinkbares wasser
haben noch alle gelacht und jetzt steht
ihr brauche ich bei edeka in der
schlange
ich kann zu hause bleiben denn ich habe
schon monate im voraus
der passt wirklich keinen cent also bis
auf die der stereoanlage die ja 30.000
gekostet aber sagt keinen cent und was
war wie der papa verarscht wurden auch
in ihren zdf auch hygieneartikel werden
in schlechten zeiten dringend gebraucht
und die sind dann nach frankes meinung
gold wert genauer gesagt mehr als gold
und jetzt wo klopapier die offizielle
deutsche währung ist sitzt ihr alle ganz
traurig auf eure schüssel so
ja ist angekommen bremer haben es immer
gewusst techno und hier was es mit der
these ausgangssperren führen zu mehr
häuslicher gewalt
ich kam super klar mit meinen mit guckst
du mich an du guckst mirjam häusliche
gewalt gut für meine familie musste ich
jetzt leider eine kontaktsperre verhängt
infektionsrisiko zu
die tür zum hof ist sicherer
[Musik]
nein zu pushen schnitt nicht einmal
bezahlt und ich bin nicht dein vater
martin klempnow
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye